c'est en un paisible bourgade des
marmottine ce que vivent depuis toujours
papa molle et les siens tout semble
encore calme et serein cela va-t-il
durer toute la journée
[Musique]
mon week end avec mon association femmes
entre elles
tu crois tu t'en sortiras oui oui oui
toi ton n'est allé aussi ya un tartuffe
à lundi
[Musique]
si vous en veniez aussi des enfants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il voudrait bien qu'on l'emmène à la
maison
regardez en liberté à condition que ton
à vois-tu de travail toi ou meurent à
manier le chien vous manquer sera la
récompense bien jouer jack
[Musique]
des leaders tourner la machine si vite
avec vantant du territoire du ch oui
vous êtes
[Musique]
dépêche toi
oui bonjour à la louche on est juste
vérifier que tout allait bien
oui tout est tout est en ordre
au nom de la loi lagarde 1
[Musique]